we are continuing to hear from people in
our audience calling in at six one seven
eight three zero
4750 let's go next to our caller from
the five one three area code who's
calling today from the five one three hi
David Pat hi Pat what's going on hey I
just want to make an observation with
the cove in nineteen have some Trump
supporting friends and they absolutely
did not believe Trump when he says but
it's a hope there's one a few things
that I've had them actually admit that
they did not believe that from what he's
saying okay so I just want to point that
part out and then secondly moving on to
the convention all the candidates said
they should but the rules play out
except for Bernie the Bernese in an
awkward position and he I think you
suggested that he would concede if he
doesn't have to pour out him and the
convention is that correct yeah yeah I
mean Bernie's done listen he's not going
to have a plurality of the delegates and
he said the person where the plurality
should win and I mean it's just it's
it's it's this is all moot at this point
yeah but I I think that he should stay
in primarily because of the shenanigans
that the the DNC's are pulling with
consolidating everyone around fighting
which kind of disrupted the entire
strategy for Bernie
yeah listen Bernie can stay in and he'll
keep accumulating delegates but remember
one point five million more people voted
for Biden than Bernie so that's not the
DNC forcing anyone to do anything the
moderates decided to get out of each
other's way there's a lot of moderates
who vote in the Democratic primary and
one and a half million more of them
voted for Biden than Bernie but listen
where are you calling from are you
calling from a body shop or a bowling
alley what's going on in a cafeteria
okay all right very good we've dealt
with a lot of that stuff basically I
appreciate it yeah thank you so much for
the call check this out the first 500
people who see this video and go to
david pakman.com slash skill
we'll get a premium membership to
Skillshare for two months completely
free skill shares the online learning
community with thousands of classes on
almost anything you can imagine always
taught by experts they have classes on
drawing painting photography video
editing web design running a small
business and much more I recently took a
very interesting class called simple
productivity how to accomplish more with
less and got a bunch of great personal
productivity tips out of it we should
allow ourselves a little time every week
to either get creative keep your brain
sharp learn something new it's great for
mental health and almost all the classes
are under an hour so it's very easy for
someone who's busy to take advantage of
it with skill share you can discover a
new passion explore something you didn't
know you would enjoy but there's also
plenty of classes for people with
experience so you can just get better at
something you're already good at and
again the first 500 people who see this
video and go to david pakman.com slash
skill will get a completely free premium
membership for two whole months giving
you access to every class Skillshare
offers check it out I put the link right
underneath this video